on est à bord du Wall rus le bateau
financé par lesent et je suis en
compagnie de Paul Watson et de Lamia oh
W la mission Ocean killer c'est une
mission qui a pour but d'observer et
dénoncer les navir de pêche usine ce
bateau peut remonter l'équivalent de la
nourriture de 30000 en un coup de
filet
[Musique]
on est sur le port de der et nous allons
rencontrer l'équipage du W rus le
nouveau bateau deard financé par les
dons du Z event
2022 c'est un Maron
caritatif million d'euros qui réunit une
cinquantaine de streamers environ chaque
année donc il y a eu 5 associations qui
ont bénéficié de ces dons de plus de
10ons 182000 € et une de ses assauts
étaéit C Shepard nous notre part elle
s'est évé à 2400000 € et du coup ça nous
a permis ben d'acheter ce super bateau
de Walrus et aussi un centre de soins en
Bretagne donc on a pu acheter 16
hectares de terrain avec une grande
maison qui sert à loger les bénévoles et
une plus petite maison qu'on a aménagé
en clinique pour les animaux c'est un
rêve de gamine que je réalise là j'ai
très très hâte parce qu'on on va
rencontrer Paul Watson qui est quand
même une figure emblématique de de se
Shepard bonjour hop là merci
beaucoup la plaque du pour remercier les
Adés incroyable bienvenu à bord là on
part en mer tu vois le phare ouais et
ben il y a des petits trucs en bas ouais
bah ça c'est des FS j'ai les petits F
avec toutes les tu les trucs et tout un
peu paradoxal la plupart des des
missions que les France réalise c'est en
haute mer et du coup on a besoin d'avoir
un bateau habitable et jusqu'àors on
avait un semi rigide c'est pas habitable
il y a pas de cabine ça va nous
permettre de rester beaucoup plus
longtemps et de d'être beaucoup plus
efficace aussi pourserver et dénoncer
les navires de pêche usine qui opèent
dans en Manche et en mer du Nord on est
arrivé là sur le deuxè en une demi-heure
c'est le zaland cette fois toujours un
navire néerlandais navire
toujours dans les EAU territoriales
françaises c'est une machine de guerre
donc on les suit on documente les pêches
et on dénonce aussi auprès de du grand
public et des autorités ah ouais s rou
ouais tu peux appuyer sur le bouton s'il
te plaît ça c'est le
stabilisateur pe t'assir devant si tu
veux ah waouh ah oui non mais c'est
c'est génial c'est toi qui va piloter
hein c'est moi qui pilote ah oui c'est
les mêmes commandes qu'en bas ça per une
meilleure vue pour pour aborder l'utre
bateau par exemple des choses comme ça
vous prenez des photos prenez des films
à part les pêcheurs et il y a personne
qui va en du coup pour c'est trop bien
de voir la concrétisation de de tout ce
que leent a pu apporter savoir que nous
on est des petits gamers derrière nos PC
savoir qu'on est suivi par plein de gens
fantastiques qui font des milliers des
millions de dons c'est c'est
incroyable c'est cool de voir que ça
peut servir comme
ça en fait je c'est une bonne idée de
que je mange là parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'à tout
moment j'ai fermé les yeux parce que je
sentais que ça allait pas du tout je
risquais de en d'autres termes rendre
mon petit
déjeuner alors là on a le jean Paul
dejoria c'est le bateau de Paul Watson
de la Fondation Captain Paul Watson il
sont avec nous pour pouvoir
documenter les navires de pêche
aussi oh là là c'est un truc de fou je
suis vachement au
là j'ai l'impression
d'être dans ma télé tu vois il y a 10
ans quand je regardais Paul Watson et
tous les équipages en lutte contre les
bateaux usin j'ai l'impression d'être
dedans B ça fait quelque chose he c'est
impressionnant les mê attraction
c'est c'est le grand
splashas déjà fait le grand
Spash c'est très grand
ici
bonjour Comment ça va enchanté enchanté
bon on s'était déjà croisé
[Musique]
est le SE pays à être présent dans tous
les océans de la planète l'apport
financier que ça va avoir mais ça ça ça
peut vraiment changer la donne pour pour
ce che France toi tu avais dit de but en
blanc voilà nous ça va servir à financer
un bateau et ben il est là il est super
utile il est vachement complémentaire
avec ce bateau là si on voit sur sur
lais la présence de navire qui nous
intéresse le Walrus il va en premier et
puis du coup il peut nous prévenir s'il
pose le filet à l'eau s'il commence à
remonter du filet là on est à la
passerelle donc c'est c'est par là qu'on
observe tout qu'on suit les bateaux on
est en communication
mais c'est un gros bateau il 7 m tu vois
ce bateau il coûte moins cher que rus ah
ouais c'est
dingue nav usine donc l'outil principal
on les a tout simplement ici sur
l'ordinateur de Na donc en fait là on
voit toutes les les petits triangles
noir sont les navires qui sont proximité
on est à moitié en France à moitié en
Angleterre on a calculé là sur les sur
une période de 48 heur on a eu jusqu'à
six gros navires usin qui pêchaient
ensemble au large de Boulogne surmer
dans les eaux territoriales et qui
pêchaient même plusieurs fois par jour
c'est énorme c'est on se demande même
comment il reste du
poisson pour donner un ordre d'idée de
l'ampleur la démesure de de cette forme
de pêche sur un coup de chalu qui relève
au bout d'une heure il pêche autant de
poissons que la nourriture nécessaire
pour 30000 fques en un seul coup de
chalu et on en a on en a comptabilisé
jusqu'à neu ils partent sur 2 semaines
enfin en fonction de de combien il pêche
mais mais quand le bateau rentre
complètement plein au port c'est 6000
tonnes de poissons à bord après ça
affecte comme tu dis les prédateurs
marins qui eux n'ont plus rien à manger
bah c'est ça et en fait le problème
c'est que on fixe les quotas de pêche
espèce par espèce sauf qu'en fait tu
peux pas faire ça avec un milieu qui est
qui est vivant où toutes les espèces
elles sont interconnectées
interdépendant les unes des autres en
fait on a encore une vision qui est qui
est complètement dépassée qui est fausse
de gérer l'océan comme comme si tu gérer
un hangar avec des stocks tu vois tuas
chaque truc qui est dans son rayon ça ça
se passe pas comme ça on dit que ce se
Shepard c'est vraiment l'ONG la plus
combbative tu vois au monde est-ce que
vous continuez de faire des actions où
vous venez entre guillemets saboter tu
vois les gros navires ou est-ce que
c'est vraiment plus de l'observation
maintenant est-ce que ça l'action a
changé en fait ça dépend c'estàd que tu
as quand tu as des actions qui sont
illégales nous on continue même sur des
sur des petites actions des petites
campagnes à récupérer des filets
illégaux mais là sur cette problématique
là on est sur des bateaux qui ont le
droit de pêcher l'objectif il est déjà
de braquer les projecteurs là-dessus
parce que si on veut que les lignes boug
il faut que les gens soient au
[Musique]
courant
vois
Mar was one of theers that made
hundising for last when we W
Theon why is it so important now that SE
she France has the wall rus how is it
different for you to have this boat you
know it's very expensive you want to
bring a big ship into port and so it's a
lot saves a lot of time and money to
have a small boat that can do that well
the main goal right now is to get as
much evidence as possible on what these
trers are doing how destructive they are
the fact that the uh the governments are
saying well they're not in our waters
when in fact we've uh uh exposed them
being well within the territorial waters
of France I mean why is a Dutch company
allowed to come and just take all of the
fish off the coast of France or off the
coast of Ireland or the UK and then take
it back to the to the Netherlands to be
turned into fish meal uh why is uh they
getting permits so it seems to me that
the government of France is more
interested and serving the interests of
the Dutch corporations that want to take
all the fish they do serving the
interest of their own people so you keep
travelling all around the world to
actually fight wherever you can well
there's problems all over the world you
go where you can you're going to disrupt
like intervene in a more let's say
violent
way well we're not going to do anything
violent uh what I uh what we do is what
I've always described as aggressive
nonviolence you know aggressively
intervening and physically intervening
but not hurting any any pas aller tu as
fait quoi du coup de le rencontrer je
réalise pas trop mais c'est c'est assez
intimidant tu es là tu do poser des
questions tu sais qu'il y a peu de temps
et c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui impose
le respect tu
[Musique]
vois à cause des conditions météo vous
allez pas pouvoir embarquer avec nous
pour être vraiment sur zone derrière le
bateau mais quand on y est très
clairement en fait tu es face à une
énorme machine de guerre qui pie
littéralement l'océan si vous voulez
avoir une idée de de à quoi ressemble un
navire comme ça de l'intérieur on a fait
une vidéo qui montre les images du
Margerie c'est le deuxième plus grand
chalutier au monde 600 m il fait
le c'est une usine flottante voilà tu
vois ça c'est la pompe qui pompe tout le
poisson tout est trié congelé célophané
mise en boî tout est absolument fait sur
place c'est vraiment une usine et là ça
descend dans les ces faut imaginer la
taille he quand tu vois tu regarde
l'image là on veut pousser à à ce qu'il
y a des des vraies études scientifiques
indépendantes pour évaluer l'impact de
ce genre de chalu géant sur le milieu
marin parce qu'en fait il y a pas
d'étude réell là-dessus et les
scientifiques soupçonnent que ils sont
la cause de déséquilibre majeur ce qui
paraît assez logique vu les quantités de
poissons qui pêchent avec l'Impact qui
se répercute sur les prédateurs marins
donc les dauphins les
oiseaux on va en cuisine en plus là
c'est une cuisine totalement végane ah
oui comme sur toutes l'émissions de se
sheeper c'est 100 % végan et tous les
mombres doivent être végan alors non
quand tu remplis ta ton formulaire de
candidature on te demande pas quelle est
ton alimentation nous on accepte tout le
monde par contre quand tu es à bord ben
tu acceptes de pas manger d'animaux ce
soir je fais un risotto de despôes
caramélisé avec du sirop d'érable et du
miso tu veux de tout hein ouis s'il te
plaît
bon là jeis juste aller dormir et voilà
au revoir bye ça c'est nos couchettes à
faire mouiller à faire mouiller à faire
mouiller chaussure
mouiller à
demain ah c'est parti
euh ça secoue fort ça secoue très
fort ah de toute façon si tu tombes tu
tombes sur le bateau oh my gosh mais tu
as vu il fait des il descend et il monte
de 2 m
ok wait c'est vraiment un super endroit
pour pour un pour
un oh wou are you ok
guys capable de monter dans le zodiaque
en toutes circonstances
bye 1 2 3 Go on est sur WR c'est
bon
luck
really oh wou qu' est jamais malade per
un peu à qui est tombé dans la soupe
quand il était petit tu vois c'est un
peu comme s'il était né
dedans and these engers everything run
main humans not
engineerseng we are Ming
crew eterrorist never work or Monsanto
that would make
me
inured
bon ben merci beaucoup tout le monde je
suis contente de rentrer en même temps
je suis triste je sais pas céit
l'aventure tu vois attention derrière
toi non je rigole tu m'as pas cru j'ai
un peu
peur c'est quand même une expérience de
fou quoi c'est dingue de voir la lutte
qu'ils ont contre ces bateau là et
toutes les actions qu'ils font ils ont
lo rus depuis un petit peu plus de de
mois ils ont fait l'inauguration il y a
2 mois et tous les jours ils sont en mer
ils font l'observation il part en lutte
voilà j'espère pouvoir un jour mettre ma
petite pireédifice si j'en ai l'occasion
c'est
[Musique]
cool